Dany bonjour bonjour Gérald bienvenue à
la drinkery la dreamquerie dans le
sud-ouest de Montréal tout à fait
Notre-Dame ici qu'est-ce qu'on fait
comme nourriture mais ici on sert à
boire et à manger on sélectionne puis on
va préparer un menu du temps des fêtes
les jeunes nous écrivent beaucoup en
nous disant le coût de la vie a beaucoup
augmenté comment je peux passer un temps
des fêtes sans me ruiner c'est ça
l'objectif est-ce que tu peux nous faire
quelque chose qui coûte pas cher puis
quelque chose d'un petit peu plus relevé
pour les gens qui ont le goût de se
gâter dans le temps des fêtes quelque
chose de modeste quelque chose
d'abbitieux oui je suis capable est-ce
que je peux t'aider certainement je t'ai
préparé t'habiller c'est gentil mais je
te préviens tout de suite je suis nul en
cuisine très nul en cuisine j'ai pas
peur on va l'en cuisine ça va être
facile tu vas voir si toi et moi on peut
réussir tout le monde peut le faire
excellent j'aime ça on y va
on va repartir à la base et se faire un
oignon moi ça va super bien bravo
général tu es capable
ok
[Musique]
on va tout simplement la déshabiller
comme une belle maîtrise la crevette ici
qui va être des boulettes parce que pour
faire quelque chose qui est économique
je me suis pourquoi pas faire des
boulettes avec du haché ce sont des
boulettes de veau je t'inviterai à
prendre ta main qui est propre et qui va
bien mélanger faire connaissance avec
les éléments
dans mon club mon club de brasseur de
viande tu comprends
il y a des gens qui achètent tous les
jours qui vont l'épicerie acheter tous
les jours
qui font ça
on a des denrées qui sont déjà payés
par exemple voilà
[Musique]
ici ce qui va être notre dessert merci
on connaît tous la baguette de nos
grands-mères je croyais que c'était des
saucisses congelés tantôt mais
simplement
encerclé le vert jusqu'à maintenant je
me sens capable de faire ça d'amis je
m'en rappelais donc ça c'est une bonne
triche regarde comme salaire onctueux
c'est du pudding à la vanille
instantanée oui évidemment on devrait
prendre un anglais
la poudre
[Applaudissements]
ça goûte vraiment ce que ça goûter il y
a 40 ans on change pas une recette
gagnante
alors quel festin c'est incroyable j'ai
hâte j'ai hâte de goûter à ça
explique-nous on préfère le tour
l'entrée maison belle rillettes de porc
si on veut le faire évoluer le GSI du
foie gras torchon
[Musique]
autour d'un potage une belle crème
d'oignon doux souvent de faire une ajout
de crevettes qui prête aussi la
langouste qui pourrait être de la chair
de homard et la version modeste est tout
aussi intéressante que celle qu'un ajout
dans le fond la denvie qui va coûter le
plus cher dans notre pôle c'est le temps
et puis on arrive donc au repas
principal repas principal j'ai décidé de
faire une twiste sur les règles
boulettes donc à la base c'est un ragoût
de boulette ici ce sont des boulettes de
veau mais j'avais proposé des boulettes
de porc avec une bonne sauce au vin
rouge des panais des carottes
multicolores des grelots une persillade
puis pour le faire évoluer j'ai racheté
des ris de veau sur lequel on a acheté
la truffe donc c'est une évolution qui
nous propose oui passer d'un plat
accessible sur le oui un plat beaucoup
plus cher beaucoup plus relevé il s'agit
de savoir cuisiner puis de se laisser se
laisser aller dans la tradition et notre
dessert le dessert c'est une bagatelle
j'ai ici qu'il y a de la vanille la
vanille là ça a eu un bon fulgurant dans
le marché médecin du trajet 10h de
Valérie dans ton dessert pour 4 de
parfums de vanille par petite verrines
qui est là quant à moi c'est du grand
luxe donc une façon d'avoir deux paliers
est-ce que ça va être meilleur bah ça va
être différent
est-ce qu'on peut goûter est-ce que tu
as fait ça se mange pour vraiment ça se
passe pour vrai le fait on a tout fait
ça ensemble
un petit peu d'huile de crevettes comme
l'huile de poilaise un petit peu plus
vilain que toi
[Musique]
en fait l'objectif de tout ça c'est de
faire en sorte qu'on puisse faites un
peu le temps des fêtes malgré
l'inflation malgré la récession qui
semble apparaître oui puis après deux
ans de pandémie où on n'a pas été
capable vraiment de péter merci Dany on
va faire ça oui puis on t'en donnera des
nouvelles tu as fait je serai là merci
[Musique]
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]